huh wants waffles and it's not my best
opener I'm tired so to heck with it okay
stranger things three because apparently
the show is too good to have them be
called seasons just numbers them like
they're like full-on sequels anyways
quick recap about my thoughts on this
show I really like season one a lot I
did not like season two very much at all
and actually I'm a double contrarian
because not only did I not like season
two of stranger things I liked Episode
seven of season two which was like the
most universally hated thing about that
season but there you go so I've now seen
season three how is it it's better than
season two it's not as good as season
one and suddenly I'm having flashbacks
to the third season of daredevil to be
completely Frank about it it's giving me
a very similar vibe a first season that
had a very clear mission statement and
knew exactly what it wanted to be a
second season that felt done partly out
of obligation and to keep the thing
going until they could get to a better
idea of how to actually continue this
thing and then a third season that feels
more thought-out and better constructed
doesn't quite hit the heights of the
first season but is definitely a step up
from the previous that's why I felt
about daredevil that's what I feel about
stranger things season 3 and it's
actually funny as I've been compiling my
thoughts it occurred to me how many
things I actually don't really like
about this season but while I was
watching they didn't bug me so much
because by the end of I'd say well not
quite the end of the first episode but
about halfway into the second episode I
felt very firmly oh this is definitely
better than the previous season so I was
having fun on that basis alone even as I
know
the part of my brain was continuing to
keep a tally of the stuff that I wasn't
really caring for but the main thing is
this manages to recapture a couple of
things that season two of stranger
things lacked the first is it manages to
recapture more of a sense of mystery and
of not being sure what it is this going
on the first season of stranger things
had that in spades it was a huge part of
why I loved it
season 2 really just didn't there were
some new elements that were brought into
play the mind flare the damodar's I
guess count as new but a lot of it was
either pretty much identical Ike the
demagogues it's just the demo core game
but it's smaller yeah we had government
agencies again yeah the way it plays out
is a bit different but it's not vastly
just similar from what we'd already seen
as far as all of that stuff goes and the
mind flayer while kind of interesting
felt in many ways like a scaling of sort
of the vibe we'd gotten from the upside
down so everything you know was a little
bit tweaked but it didn't it didn't feel
like it was a big unknown it was just
like oh yeah that makes sense
whereas this season stopped very early
on starts happening I'm like what is
going on like wait a minute how does
that work with what and that was good to
feel again it was good not to just watch
let me have me go oh yeah that makes
sense because that's what a lot of
season two was for me the other thing is
this one feels a heck of a lot more
focused and and has done a better job of
finding stuff for characters to do not
all of them but more than season two did
because I and this is one of the reasons
why I think follow-up seasons are never
gonna be as good as season 1 for this
season 1 aside from just the surprise
factor and you can only recap that to
certain extent after the first time one
thing season one had that
had really well was it had a solid
central premise so that was will buyers
missing everything circled around that
every character that was brought in was
in some way connected to that so
everyone who was in the story was in the
story because of how they related to
either will or wills disappearance or
how his disappearance happened
everything came back to that season to
do not have a strong central focus at
all instead it just brought back all the
characters that had been in the previous
season because they were in the previous
season they were no longer there because
they were connected to a central core
concept they were there because well
they were here last time and the whole
thing just lacked focus it lacked thrust
it lacked just a sense of everything
being properly connected as opposed to
being connected by sheer frigging
coincidence and while season 3 doesn't
fully get back to season season one's
level of a clearer centralized issue
that things tie into it certainly has
something closer to that than season 2
did it's a little bit unfocused some of
the characters they still haven't found
great stuff to do Nancy and Jonathan
honestly they they have not found much
for them to do since the first season
they have a little bit more point than
they did in the second season in so much
as the their role is to basically be the
people who keep discovering exposition
so like they serve a plot function as
far as that goes but like as characters
they just feel like they're there to dig
stuff up and to help deliver some
exposition and make sure that certain
things get discovered so they are a
little bit max who was introduced in
season 2 and who I didn't really take to
I was left thinking what's the point of
view is used much better here I liked
her a lot more especially I really liked
her interactions with 11 I thought that
those were those were quite good
copper's weird in this one I feel like
they took some of the moments that were
great
cathartic moments of hopper and then
tried to make that his entire character
this season and it's off and mainly I'm
talking about him just kind of being a
bit of a thug like when he would kind of
just go heck with it
in previous seasons like it felt built
up to you know it felt you felt his
frustration builds at that point you
felt his desperation at what was going
on you you really wanted to see whoever
you hit get hit this season isn't
totally devoid of that but it feels like
they've stripped away a lot of his
character that isn't frustrated and
angry and a little too gruff and
pigheaded like I feel like whatever else
there was there besides that it's kind
of gone now which is a bit of a
disappointment he didn't become a bad
character I still enjoy having him
around but yes something's just a little
weird a little off with him
Joyce is still good as far as the kids
go they are they are fun not all of them
have as much to do as others mike is
kind of the most useless he's the bigger
hang he's the biggest hanger on that
said it was nice to have will have more
to do because will has has felt mostly
like a victim first two seasons so for
him to have a bit more agency and have a
bit more to do that was nice
Lucas you know is just kind of funny as
a good dynamic Dustin gets a fair bit to
do Lucas his little sister Erica gets
featured a bit more she's she's quite
fun
Steve Steve still great Steve was one of
the highlights of season two and you
know his sort of transformation from you
know the the height the high school
hotshot a little bit of a bully kind of
a douche in the first season to like the
world's best babysitter haha in the
second season he kind of continues that
trajectory as life
continuing to give him not what he
expected he was gonna get but he kind of
takes it in his stride I really like
Steve a lot and they also paired him
with a new character who I love and
that's Robin so Steve Steve has gotten
himself stuck into you know a post high
school couldn't get into college style
job which is he is slinging ice cream at
the local mall and his coworker is Robin
and Robin is awesome she has a fantastic
dynamic with Steve she has a great
chemistry with Dustin when they started
interacting she is just a lot of fun
there's also some stuff that goes on
with her later on that I'm not gonna
spoil at least not early in the review
that I really loved
but overall um like is it a step up from
season two I'm gonna start to get into a
bit more detail now and that is gonna
mean to a certain degree its spoilers so
if you have not seen all of season three
I'm not gonna do like a full plot
breakdown but I just got to talk about
the other things that I want to talk
about some of which will include
spoilers you have been warned so the
whole thing with the mind flayer it was
it was actually kind of cool because and
I mentioned recapturing that blood is
going on and that started out like with
the rats like all I'm asking you this
place in them they just start like
exploding at like what is going on and
then the thing kind of takes over Billy
and I'm like what is going on and I'm
like are we getting an invasion of the
body snatchers like what is this like
not in a this doesn't fit way but just
in a I wouldn't have expected this and
I'm intrigued way and then as you know
later seeing the bodies like come
together and reform cuz it was kind of
cool because the mind flayer before had
been this very sort of ethereal smoke
like shadowy thing so now to see it made
up of goop and melted must
and viscera and teeth it's it's kind of
cool cuz it's that same design but it's
like that is not made of the same stuff
Oh Lord so like that was neat and I
enjoyed that I did feel that from like
it it's getting its full reveal through
the defeat was just kinda it just kind
of plugged along it didn't let me down
at any point but he just kind of plugged
along the way that I would have expected
it to and certain points of resolution
really were like exactly what I expected
I didn't expect that Hopper was gonna
die um but I did I did like from the
beginning called that Suzie was gonna
end up showing up at the end and being
real and all that and you know but it's
still kind of nice
predictable does not always mean
unsatisfying sometimes what you expected
can be nice that said in the case of
somebody like stranger things because
that first season was so unexpected any
season that even though may be pleasant
and enjoyable if it is more predictable
than season one was it still feels like
it's missing a little something which
the season is kind of a bit I have mixed
feelings about the whole Russian subplot
especially for the time the idea that
the Russians are also kind of trying to
do this same sort of thing instead of
this whole secret base or whatever I'm
cool with that I also like Alexi as a
character initially I was the noir when
they brought back that conspiracy nut
and that felt like kind of crowbar Dan
and contrived except like he had a fun
dynamic with the characters and ER I do
what some like well fine give it a pass
um I didn't need the Russian Terminator
like I don't know what the character's
name was I don't know if it ever got set
but he was he did that's what he was it
was the Russian Terminator didn't need
him at all really didn't care if I
thought he was laughable just as a
concept and watching him kind of stomp
around yeah no didn't didn't care for
him but overall I kind of like how some
of the team are sort of try and figure
out what's going on with Billy and then
working it on the mind flayer whereas
Stephen Robin and Eric and Dustin are
figuring out the Russian stuff and then
everything comes to a head like I said
it does it does depend a bit more in
coincidence than I would have liked but
they do all come together and again it
gives everybody something to do except
Mike cause Mike kinda sucks I'm sorry he
just does um oh I didn't love Joyce and
hopper like starting to become a thing
that felt like unnecessary fanservice
it was something fans were calling for
and they just kind of did I'm like why
like why I just and like maybe it was
hinted at more previous seasons I'm sure
somebody will tell me if it was but like
I just I still don't like it I just
don't
um I mean effects we're good you would
have expected that from this it's
atmospherically shot the music's really
cool I feel like I don't know if I'm
just becoming more sensitive to them I
feel like the call-outs to a tease pop
culture are getting more and more
blatant like I felt like they so the
call-outs have always been pretty
upfront like the tapping into the
nostalgia for the air at set it is a big
part of this show's appeal it wears that
on a sleeve but I feel like they kind of
stopped the plot dead to go hey new coke
Hey
the neverending story theme song I'm
like you you're you're not integrating
it into the story you're stopping the
story to go hey it's practically a
product placement the only difference is
the only difference is is for products
that aren't being sold new anymore so
that was a little weird okay I need to
come back under this because I mentioned
Robin so I want to be very clear about
this and again spoilers um I don't love
Robin because she's gay I loved Robin
well before she revealed she was gay
that said the reveal the way it's done
and the way Steve reacts once he digests
that information I love
I love the way she tells him I love how
he kind of takes a minute to process and
then just starts ribbing her for the
girl that she had a crush on like I love
it he just transitioned into that I love
Steve Steve's great and it just made
that dynamic all the better I've seen
some people actually call out that the
show is hinting that will might be gay
that wasn't my read on it I was actually
reading him more as asexual but I wasn't
then I was reading him gay but it's not
made explicit either way I just wanted
to toss that out there as well overall I
had a good time watching this and which
is nice because a lot of follow up
seasons have become slogs for me for a
lot of shows that started out strong and
I used to like at some previous point
like I've started the third season of
Jessica Jones I've gotten all of one
episode in and I'm just not motivated to
keep going I will I'll finish it but
like kind of don't wanna or at least I'm
not excited to do it but stranger things
3 while I have a fair number of nitpicks
and like while I'm always happy to see
Carrie always having him basically just
be the mayor from Jaws only more corrupt
you know that there's there's plenty of
nitpicks for me to throw out that that
hopper Nancy and Jonathan there's lots
for me to pick up but overall I can't
argue with fun and at the end of the day
I had fun with this season so those are
my thoughts on season 3 of us stranger
things usually no what do you think
about it whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it bunch of stuff down there
to do including hit the like button
which you've been doing lately and it
has actually been helping so please keep
it up if you can't I've also got a
PayPal tip jar or if you want to keep me
going on a sustained basis there's the
patreon down there as well
plus links to my book and merch and blah
blah blah blah tons of links down there
click on them they'll take you places
but you don't have to cuz at the end of
the day you're the council and I'm just
running the meetings so until next time
this council
is adjourned
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]